if it goes most everywhere how can we
minimize the damage so there's a number
of considerations there the first
standard one is don't overload the
medical system spread it out over time
and that means some degree of lockdown
but it not nearly as much as if you're
trying to squash it contain this thing
but people do overestimate the value of
medicine so that's a bit much what else
can we do we could make sure that the
young were the ones initially exposed
more than the old because they have much
lower death rate from this so we need to
get some level of her divinity which
might be you know some roughly half the
population but why not have it be the
young half the healthy half rather than
the old and sick half and that that's
also capable of dramatically reducing
the death rate and then we could try to
make sure that people were deliberately
infected just so we can control when and
where it happened so most of the
lockdown is to present prevent a tiny
fraction of us from infecting others the
tiny fraction who are at the moment
infected but since we don't know who's
who were locking down everybody if you
deliberately infected some people at a
controlled location and time then you
could isolate them there and you know
use your isolation resources far more
effectively and it also allows you to
spread out the medical resources over
time you can choose to stay do it
earlier than the peak or later than peak
right so just the idea of deliberate
infection if we're going to mostly all
get an exposed has those substantial
advantages you know get the young and
healthy and get you know the control of
the isolation resource but in addition
to these advantages there's apparently a
prospect a very likely prospect that
there are big advantages in how
someone's infected so for most viruses
we know there are a dose effect that is
the initial dose that you get of the
virus matters a lot so for example if
there's a droplet in the air how many
viruses are in that droplet or how many
droplets do you breathe in the first few
minutes where you're getting infected
it's a tiny droplet with very few
viruses that's a low dose you know
you touch a door hot knob an hour after
somebody else touched it then that may
also be a low low dose but if you get
infected say at home by kissing your
infected spouse you're gonna get a big
dose and we've have a lot of data on
other diseases that show low doses can
have much lower morbidity and mortality
you get hurt a lot less and in fact
before we have vaccines we were using
variolation in particular for smallpox
so for example in the United States
during the Revolutionary War u.s. troops
in Canada were hit by smallpox and
devastated and that's why basically the
Canada's a separate country because
those crew troops couldn't fight the war
there George Washington was worried
about this and even though Continental
Congress had outlawed variolation
intentional infection at low doses he
ordered it for the US troops anyway in
secret so that the enemy wouldn't attack
while they were sick and basically this
reduced the death rate from smallpox
from twenty to thirty percent down to
one to two percent and that allowed us
to win the Revolutionary War is to worry
that if we did this there's too much
societal pressure or like the the
headlines of hey the way to solve this
is to actually intentionally infect
people with low dosage and and we just
can as a society even if the science
shows that it's effective we can't get
there because there's so much fear and
uncertainty in kind of the press or do
you feel like it's actually viable that
we could do this so there's a difference
between we all deciding to do it
together as a joint policy enforced and
some of us deciding to do it because we
want to so we don't there are many
problems with the pandemic that we need
to do everything together
there are collective problems but this
isn't one of them if we have a low dose
way to get infected and we allow some
people get infected that way that helps
and we don't have to require them or
even agree together that we should we
just have to allow it so and in fact
people are
in a sense allowed to get infected but
the problem is the people who would
supply the infection aren't allowed to
supply it because of regulations of
drugs and medical ethics impairment so
actually the current limitation is that
we would just need a hundred or so
people to just do a small trial and we
can't get medical ethics approval to do
those small experiments because the
people who run epics experiments say
this is unethical because in their
calculation the benefit to society of
finding a way to lower our death rate by
a factor of 10 it doesn't count the only
thing that counts is these people might
by getting attracted yes that can get
hurt and that's just the rule but in
that trial those people would be opting
into this right this man to your point
that's still not allowed so a medical
ethics calculations say we're not
allowed to let people volunteer now of
course that's against our practice in
the military and for firefighters and
police there's lots of people in our
society who we allow to take risks for
us and we pay them but the medical
ethics interpretation is that's not to
be allowed to people who take medical
experiments that's just their decision
of what ethics is and they are not
budging in this crisis I mean it sounds
pretty ridiculous right I immediately
thinking of I saw a video online in a
prison where prisoners were basically
gathered in a circle and what it was
being described and of course we don't
know with a hundred percent certainty
but was being described in the video is
that they were one of them was positive
for coronavirus and they were actually
trying to infect each other so that they
could get out eight which sounds pretty
ridiculous but basically you're talking
about he's a much more medically driven
or scientific driven version of that no
Lucas right so the key problem with
people just getting infected in that way
first is they're not getting a low dose
or trying to make sure that they're
getting a low [ __ ] but also they're not
being isolated preventing it from
spreading so what I recommend is
something that I called a hero hotel you
you go there you pay to go there and
then they immediately infect you and
keep you there until you're recovered
and so you're not inflaming the whole
pandemic you are just getting
this treatment and getting past it now
you know people may well want to do that
for many reasons so not just wanting to
help society to get us all past this but
they themselves could get back to work
afterwards and get back to socializing
and we get back to their lives and uh
you know there many people are really
quite frustrated at being locked down so
I've heard many people say informally
that they sure wish they could find a
way to just get past this and they'd be
willing to take some risks but what we'd
like to do is to have them have a much
lower risk by doing it deliberately and
all we need is some small trials and see
unfortunately the problem is if people
can sit in a circle with an infected
person and try to get them that's
legally allowed but we are not legally
allowing doctors say to do something
like this because the treatment hasn't
been medically approved and as a company
you couldn't sell people something that
let them be affected with the low dose
because that hasn't been approved by
regulators and so we're in this sad
situation where you legally be allowed
to do the worst thing but not the better
things because you know we holding
basically these companies and
professionals to much higher standards
than we hold individuals